Monday night's episode of The  Bachelorette took us to new musical and  emotional Heights after a two-on-one  date Jojo sent Derrick home as don't cry  for me Argentina plays  in other Bachelorette news it was our  first episode of the season without Chad  so we were definitely in need of some  drama Jordan and James literally argued  about the rules of poker  how does one act entitled when stating  that the rules of a game are suck and  Jojo ended the episode like this  I just couldn't hand out that final road  yeah she did not send anyone home at the  rose ceremony so what do you think of  the show without Chad let us know on  twitter @dnews